hi
i don't normally mention names and
when i do it's because i feel it it's an
important
part of the making of the film
but if if at any time the people i'm
speaking about or anybody's offended or
upset
by the direct names that i'm
mentioning please let me know and i'll
remove the film or
i'll try to make it right
with them i'd like to mention
a very well respected teacher
and he's been on ike journal
a while back bruce bookman
and he
is an interesting i find him interesting
because of the way he talks about aikido
and how
he's showing applications and
and so that made me start thinking about
aikido in
in the in different forms you know
different tears we'll say
if my last film i was talking about
things evolving and
oh sensei took aikido from many
different arts as we know
and dietary was more i would say
locks and pins and applications
rather than the flowing art that we
we mainly see and do in the dojos
so the way i
see aikido over the years if you're
around long enough to
progress is
first the techniques and the
technique should include
pins locks locking the joints
and it's more we'll say of teaching you
how to
immobilize somebody but perhaps better
in a in a fight mode because there's not
many gifted people
that start aikido and carry on
in such a way that they're enlightened
from day one
and i know in my case young
man 23 very strong powerful
in strength strong in mind eager
ego opinionated male chauvinistic
pig or say all the all the things that
i would perhaps not wish to be
thought of now i'm sure there's
other things people think of me that
perhaps not so good either but
so if we take the first level
learn the strict
pins and locks but learn them with an
attitude that you can
disarm somebody and perhaps you might
even have to look at another martial art
to do this
like i said bruce bookman you can look
him up
and see what he says
but he's showing people how to defend
their self
with with adapting skills taking skills
from
other arts because aikido really
is a complicated art that doesn't really
have any
i don't know if it's because it hasn't
been round long enough does something
have to be around a thousand years
before
you can say it's a stable art
being over 100 years old isn't
very old at all is it
but we don't seem to have any basis
any firm grounding it's a
it's more of a free-for-all really well
that's what it appears to me
i didn't see it this way until i started
traveling much further afield
than the dojo in cambridge
you know when i was a orange belt i
started going
oh it may have been a yellow belt but
more sandwich belt
fourth q did i then start going to
what we called the mecca the hut in
hillingdon in london
near heathrow airport a wooden
shack still there today renovated but
um it was known as the
the place to go for aikido
if you didn't come off the the mat at
the end of class
what the hut is in the pub
car park or sorry next to the
pub car park it's behind the pub
so after standard practice after a good
hard training you'd go in the pub enough
that's two pints of beer these are the
days when
you could drink and drive because it
wasn't
so strict now of course we know we
shouldn't have done it but we did then
i used to drink orange juice so i was
okay
i didn't really like the taste of beer
so when i was let's say 24
years of age i would go to
the heart if i didn't come off i didn't
want to come off with
either a half dislocated finger or
stamped on toe that might go
blue it might not
or i may have got a bruise on the cheek
where somebody was quick enough to hit
me and i was not quick enough to get out
of the way
and the reason was they were they were
going to hit me they were
that was the fun of it fun was
get tony or tony gets them
so we really were closer to fighting
without the anger but we had all the ego
the want the desire so that's pretty
close
to what we should be wanting to find
and so therefore
it was more real so the first level of
aikido as i
believe it to be is the technical stage
of hard physical training where the body
does get a little damaged it hurts
hopefully nothing gets broken sometimes
it does
these days have gone because of all the
the correctness
what it does in the uk now we would um
not be able to train like that it's not
a case of wanting to do it
i'm just telling you how it was
and and real fighting skills
do get their knocks you know you don't
go in a boxing ring
and put all your padded gear on
for nothing it's so that the the boxing
can be
hard and fast but without
true damage and in the aikido we don't
pad up like that do we
so the first level
is technical hard physical
training of breaking one's body
i believe that osensi mentioned it
first we must fight ourself
we are the demon of our own making
and by training hard like this on
technic in technical
techniques we slowly break ourself
it's not that we don't want it anymore
but we evolve
to me that's evolving we evolve into
a person that starts to see that
instead of it being all abruptness and
technical
it can flow and we start to see
a flow in our movements may not be a
great flow
but we try to smooth the edges out so
we're still doing the
severe techniques and pins and locks
but we're flowing we're smoothing out
going from one
point to the other
this is the next stage of our
involvement
evolving into the next
part we like to see the flow but if we
start to flow too much
we notice with this hard severe training
that we've done earlier
that holes are starting to come in the
security of the technique
we're enjoying the flow we're enjoying
the beauty of it
but small weaknesses start to come in we
may be stepping
without thinking just on the in the
wrong
angle the
the spot where we should be didn't seem
to matter so much because we were
enjoying the flow
but our mind reminds us if we've had the
hard training before
and that we need to go
back to basics and look at what we're
missing
we we're going ahead too quickly into
flow
so once we get
past the flow
we're starting to make everything more
harmonious
and more spiritual between us and the
attacker
so when cytosensei said dozer please go
past
he's not just saying please go past
he's saying when i'm performing a
technique
on my attacker i must not hinder them
by being in the way this means
not stopping in a static position not
stopping in front of them
so if you're to do shia nagi do it like
water pushing a logger down the stream
do the sheer naggy at the pace of the
flow
do a coat of gosh at the pace of the
when coming to meet anikio do it
at the pace of a flow never make it
a clash an abruptness make it
a flow of flow
then we get to many other stages
that's the beauty of aikido
if somebody gives me a house brick one
brick is really good for door stop
might hold some papers down
in the wind or keep on your desk but i
can't build a house with that can i
i need a lot of bricks to build a house
so this is what you're doing by slowly
going through the correct stages not the
stages
that your teacher might want you to go
through
well everybody's in a rush everybody
wants to get to
what a sense he had but nobody wants to
put in the time
go so she oda said this
everybody wants an easier path they
don't realize the path is hard
path is severe
so if you want to do the different
stages
then learn what each stage should be
and you may never get to the ultimate
stage i'm
trying to get to the stage of where i
sense he wanted us to be
and that is the art of peace
peace within ourself really
if you find peace within yourself you'll
find peace
when confronted being confronted by
others
because you're you'll be thinking i
don't want to fight you please go past
and you'll do everything in your
ability to let them go past
or to defuse a situation the last thing
you want to do is fight
you will all those techniques
won't be necessary because like i sense
he said
there's thousands of
aikido techniques in takamusu aikido
he said when you need one one will be
born
and he doesn't really mean a whole coat
of guy shall come out
it could just be a little press
here or it could be a press on a nerve
it could be a clamp in the throat rather
than
push under the chin
it could be a pressure point in the
windpipe
it doesn't you see these but you won't
have to think about it
if you've done enough like you know and
enough techniques
one will be created for you at the
appropriate time
but only when you need it if you have
doubt
that because you haven't trained in
aikido for many years
then you are lost
and you didn't really train correctly in
the first place
if you rely on what i sense he said
a technique will be born takamusa will
will happen it will be achieved
but what we have to do
is find the enemy within
and work out the stages and then perhaps
we can get
closer to our senses real art
thank you for listening